this is joe Matarese I got problems and
they need fixing
on the right all right you're gonna have
to go through hell question any
nightmare that you have a drink if I can
change then you can change
you're listening to fixing Joe every
week I'm gonna bring my real life
problems with this podcast my friends my
listeners my guests my family they're
all gonna help me and trust me i need it
i got tons of problems I'm anxious I
have OCD I have a DD I'm narcissistic
I'm insecure I got anger out the ass and
all these things come together to ruin
my life all the time I'm hoping the show
can help you're listening to fixing Joe
I hey everybody another fixing Joe how
are you great podcast lined up we have
we have our guest Paul her Z skyped in
via I don't know where I never know the
town you live in Paul where's the town
you live in North Salem I live up yeah i
live in Nam yes I live in Newton the
northern the most northern east part of
westchester county that's north salem
right that's the name of the town yes so
we have we have Paul verzi on the
podcast it's been a while we got a lot
of subjects to cover someone gave me
[ __ ] cuz I don't know if you do this
Paul on your podcast i mentioned the
like the plug type [ __ ] right at the
beginning and then then there's always
someone because you eat you come on your
podcast and you say give give give want
want want yeah and they like they're
annoyed by me because they they say oh
your wife's a doctor and why are you
asking for stuff like they think because
my wife has a PhD I'm a millionaire and
they think I'm spending over my means
which I am but do you do at the top of
your podcast you do you do your plugs or
do you go right into your podcast I just
know I talk about the sponsors you know
I say you know the verge effect podcast
is sponsored by you know the people that
I you know that I obviously on board
with what i'm doing and i just plugged
them and then i go into my podcast yeah
that's what that's what I do so I you
know get the plugs out of the way and
then we can just talk right i mean yeah
that's the way to do it so so let's get
my plugs really quick if you want to
make a donation i think this is why that
one fan gave me [ __ ] as I said I was
hurting for money when I was at
for donations which it's like you can't
be honest I thought a podcast is a place
I could be honest i'm having a shitty
financial summer uh which we'll talk
about on this podcast i keep having gigs
get cancelled or almost get cancelled or
Booker's being dicks and doing weird
[ __ ] i've had a lot of shitty financial
moves on the comedy industry done to me
this this summer so i'm asking for a
good donation so go to joe Matarese calm
you'll notice the new splash page I'm
about to have a new website done and
it's not completely done but there's a
nice little splash page up there one
pager and it has all the all the stuff
you need to make a donation twenty
dollars more get you to CDs and a pair
of earbuds from my sponsor tweaked audio
um what else do we have we have live
gigs which paul i don't know you coming
the levity live tonight I am so you
could see Paul and myself I'm going to
be headlining at levity live in west
nyack new york tonight in the palisades
center mall that's thursday tonight 730
show go to joe Matarese calm you don't
even need to go to the levity live
website to buy the tickets with the new
splash page just click on the link right
there and it'll take you right to where
you can buy tickets come on out tonight
got a seven-thirty show also be in new
haven connecticut at jokers wild which I
want to talk to paul about in a couple
of seconds Joker's wild is the 31st of
July and the first of August go to joe
Matarese calm and click on the link of
their four Joker's wild and you can buy
tickets to that okay what other plugs
Jesus crazy stuff I'm starting
businesses now I you can if you're
interested in hiring me to do some
distress painting or painting in your
house you're gonna laugh but it's up on
my facebook page some of this [ __ ] that
I've painted is up there put a little
professional proposal with all my work
go check out my facebook page it's the
joe Matarese on facebook and check it
out do want to hire me i can do it and i
can ship you the ship you when I'm when
I'm done I actually got hired already to
do somebody do somebody's a california
king size bed
all right we'll get some more plugs at
the end of the podcast it's just too
much at the top vers II listened to
Paul's podcast he does it every week
it's called the verzi effect and it's
blowing up it's a great podcast I'm sure
they can listen to it on your website or
on podbean is that where they can listen
to the vers eff yeah the verse effect I
all things comedy podbean itunes yep
yeah go check it out their minds up on
all things comedy also but for some
reason they're having a problem and it's
it the newest podcast for me is five
months old on the all things comedy
website I have no idea why they're
trying to fix it okay so we got a lot to
talk about i just took us an hour to set
up skype by the way [ __ ] you Scott sky
you know yeah because you know what it
is with these all of these things like
they oh it's like if it's not broken
every time you go to something and you
think you have a password and you think
you have the username and you're all
excited to do it and you're ready to do
it they're like oh you need to update
the version to 9.1 did you do that yet
and it's like no I didn't it's true as
soon as it works it doesn't work soon as
you figure out the old 1i here's the new
one I don't ever with my iPhone I don't
know if you do this I don't ever
download the new software no I got it it
works I agree with you it's so annoying
it's like yeah like you can't get into
this if you didn't update did you up did
you install the new and it's like no man
I don't I mean like everything is did
you install the new version and they
keep changing versions it's like this is
working exactly I was trying a bit last
night that I'm officially at an age
where when my phone's broken I just hand
it to anybody who's 20 is in front of me
I just go make this work and I said
unless my email it goes off I don't
think it went like if i don't hear the
crush it didn't go i don't know i just i
i do i and I used to be savvy I used to
be good at all electronics I've said
this on my pockets before I was the guy
they came to your house to make your VCR
work or to hook your hdmi cables up I
was the guy
but nah not anymore it's just it's it's
gone through a whole nother level and
I'm not going to the apple store to take
some school or a Class AA on how to use
iMovie I you know if I can't figure it
out on my own without directions i'm not
i'm not either kind of like this if i'm
taking money out of my wallet i'm not
i'm not that should pay for everything
i'm not doing anything else I'm buying
yeah you know I mean yeah we're
comedians I don't think we know how to
sit down and read directions and figure
it out yet do you ever go on youtube for
anything and like learn try to learn how
to do something you ever use it you know
I got a lot no I know a lot of people
that do that and they'll like um yeah I
think one time it was funny one time I
did to see how to set up my cigar
humidor like so to have a guide or what
yeah I got a humidor so what is a
humidor do actually it like that it
makes the cigars fresh you just keep him
in there for a long forever yeah what
the humidor has this little filter that
you soak in water and then after you
soak it in water it sticks to velcro on
the top and when you close it it kind of
just keeps the box moist and it keeps
the cigars moist so I wanted to just see
like when I got the box a good friend of
mine extremely funny and talented
comedian you know him to great friend of
mine yanez papas for my birthday yanez
bought me he bought me a big humidor
because he's like man you smoke so many
sticks you gotta have a humidor so he
got it for me and it was like a nice one
that's a good gift yeah as a great gift
and he came with like a cigar holder and
a cutter and the ashtray in the humidor
but like I didn't know how do you like
has set it up so I went on you two I was
just watching all these guys that love
cigar it's just like so into it it was
cool that's the only time that I've
really done that but yes so to answer
your question yes I bet you're a good
gift receiver i bet you know did you did
you tear off and you're lucky I'm a
terrible gift receiver like when you
give me something great I open it like
it's not great I don't know why I get it
from my dad my dad's terrible at
receiving gifts no there's nobody worse
at receiving gifts to my dad because he
actually shows his displeasure to you
it's too honest like he's way too honest
like he'll just like I remember one time
I got my dad a book it was Rodney
Dangerfield's of autobiography
and I thought it was a cool gift because
when I was a kid and back to school came
out my dad actually took me to see
Rodney at Radio City and I'll never
forget it uh you know what's the guy's
name Nelson jet what's in Nelson
nutballs Bob Nelson came out and opened
and then Dangerfield came out and you
know back to school was a hit so I like
you know I figured my dad wants to you
know I got the book i love the book so i
got the book from my dad and I remember
handed in the book and like as he as he
was getting the gift he didn't know what
book it was he just knew it was a book
and he just goes what so what book did
you get me like what dislike almost like
disappointed that it was a book I was
just like oh no he gave me reading oh
yeah I remember one time just [ __ ]
hilarious my dad gave me something and I
think like it was something he used and
then didn't want it anymore I think my
dad is the king of too honest like you
get that you have that I have that too
right you one hundred percent I've
watched you I've watched you shoot
yourself in the foot because of it
that's oh that's why that's why you get
into it at comedy clubs cuz you're the
only guy in the world that I would get
to a comedy club and like first time out
just go onstage like owners Booker's
there you would just go these lights
Jesus set this up yeah that's almost to
the point where I have to pull the club
owner or Booker aside before I go on and
go and give him a speech like hey man
just get letting you know in advance i'm
gonna probably make fun of about six
things about your establishment and i
don't mean it I I love it here but
that's it's how I get comfortable on
stage I have to say things about the
bathroom fan that was too loud or you
know I love when you go to the shitty
gigs where they don't put the mint they
don't have one of those those mints in
the in the urinal they have ice here
Bengali i went i did a gig one sir they
had the ice in there and I made fun of
that for ten minutes like and so
hopefully you know close you get all
this from your dad I'm lost so my dad
recently my mom and dad gave me [ __ ] for
like a year cuz we didn't have
dining room chairs we have this
expensive restoration hardware table no
chairs and they kept saying [ __ ] when
are you gonna get chairs when are you
gonna get chairs really know we're
looking for the right ones we don't have
that much money right now chairs are
expensive my wife finally picks out
chairs I send a picture of them to my
mom and dad and I text it to them and
they don't text back so I'm like you
never know what parents they might have
just not known how to open a picture so
i called him i go did you get the text
of the pic with the picture of the new
shares my dad just pause as he goes yeah
we got it gotta be honest oh boy I was
underwhelmed because and so was your
mother oh I'm what but I'm finally at a
point in my life where I went that means
they look good cuz you don't I I you
don't have good taste we need it's I
said this to you recently like with
movies he goes off you gotta go see Ted
2 and then I look at the reviews it gets
like a forty percent on rotten tomatoes
and then I think you told me you saw and
said it's alright and I go no I me I
mean the one thing I've learned though
is as good and accurate as rotten
tomatoes can be they could also be as
bad because rotten tomatoes has [ __ ] on
a lot of movies that were really decent
movies and I'm noticing that rotten
tomatoes has like a bias against certain
things like if you notice they're
consistent with the same types of movies
so you can't always go with them and
I'll say this Ted to was definitely not
Ted one bro and sure no no I mean the
first Ted was classic Ted to had like
those four or five like insanely
laugh-out-loud moments right but it was
just you know but I mean at the end of
the day you watching a movie about a
teddy bear so what are you gonna you
know you know what it was Ted to to me
was more like an episode of family guy
even more than the first one it was like
a regular episode of family guy right
but ya know I did they veer off and unto
parodies on a TV screen and [ __ ] like
that like certain stuff they did that
would definitely like the show but I
know what you're saying as far as like
when certain people don't like something
like ever talk to somebody and they
think a comedians great or they were
they so
yeah they'll just be like oh my god did
you so and so and you're like you know
you could tell that it's just not your
type of deal you know well I guess it
that could be a premise on stage at
probably work where you have a friend
that you go up but you always call it
going Oppo instead of opposite you go
call going up oh you would you go
opposite like he likes it you know it
sucks and if it's if he hated it you
know you got to go see it like that's
how I am like my friend gene that I grew
up with he's been on my podcast is one
of my best friends and you know I've
known since high school if the camera
moves around like if the if the
directors trying to get artsy he hates
it like he's like dude the camera was
moving like you know how like the office
has that style with the yeah the he
can't stand that if it if it's stylish
in there zooming in and out out of
nowhere to look like a documentary but
it's not a documentary yeah this is a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I remember I saw a
movie with him what was that movie with
Jennifer Aniston was really an older one
um I think it was called something girl
there was a scene where somebody like
was having sex and a dog kept barking in
the background it was a classic scene in
the movie I forget what it was called
something girl and she was the lead in
it and he must I go with Gene and it was
an artistic movie and he must have left
40 times yeah and we leave the theater
he goes boy I was a piece of [ __ ] I go
you left 40 times that's a win what are
you talking about unless you were
laughing at how bad it was what you
weren't I mean there was a funny movie
all right look we got to get to the the
list I got so much stuff to talk about
on this podcast and so much stuff that I
didn't that I didn't even watch like I'm
sure we're gonna talk about Caitlyn
Jenner and I don't even know if I want
to ask you because I have it on my DVR I
want to watch the ESPYs did you see it
it's funny you should say that because
last night I went down to the city I did
a spot hung out for a while got home
went online and did something and I saw
LeBron I saw clip LeBron James present
an award to that Devin steel guy the guy
in the bangle
who's young daughter has cancer and it
was really a motor was amazing yeah you
saw that so i watch that and then as I'm
scrolling I just see you know Bruce
Jenner dressed in that you know the
whole Caitlyn Jenner thing and I see him
up there I was like I gotta watch this
see how I was like I gotta watch it so
it was like 27 minutes when the
presenter came out and they show the
whole story they did a piece on him
which was about twenty minutes and he
comes out with this like almost ten
minute speech and they did a 20 the the
whole thing from when the for the whole
thing the whole Arthur Ashe award of
courage from when the presenter came out
and talked about it to the piece they
did to his speech the whole thing was 27
minutes oh okay I thought you were at it
and I like it was an hour okay no no no
I'll do presented it the whole Bruce
Jenner piece was 27 minutes and you know
it was who was the presenter the
presenter was that Abby Wambach uh I
believe she I mean I don't quote me this
but I think the reason why they had her
come out was because she's uh I think
she's might be might be gay or whatever
but she she was the women's soccer the
women's soccer uh you know us they just
won the World Cup who should remain she
was on the main you know one of the main
ones she was bro that got the three
goals she the hat trick room on all the
the girl I got the three goals was a
younger girl from Jersey this was like
the veteran like she's a veteran she's
been on national team for years and
years and she finally got it she's older
she's like you know okay yeah so she
came out and she presented it and she
was like you know I hope this if the
story should touch you the way that it
touched me and blah blah blah and then
they just showed a piece that they did
and they really did a good job of it
because they broke down they showed him
in the Olympics you know coming close in
72 and then how much he dedicated his
life to getting it in 76 how just he was
like a man's man and a guy's guy and
like America needed something like that
at the time and he was it and then like
while they're doing it they're showing
him sitting on a couch as Caitlyn Jenner
and it was just really interesting how
they did it and what he said was amazing
you know he was talking about he was
just talking about how kids are being
bullied kids are killing themselves and
like
the transgender thing is like kids are
being murdered and it's really like
rough and then he started naming some
people that either committed suicide or
going through something and he said the
one that sticks out was this one guy
that committed suicide and it was like
only a couple days before his Diane
Sawyer thing came out and he was
thinking wow you know would that have
changed anything and he just kind of
making people aware but his message was
nice like I got something funny to say
afterwards okay but but but let me just
say this he he said like if we could
treat people with respect and as human
beings and let people be who they are
like the world would be better and the
way that he did it was really nice and
then he got emotional we talked about
his family but dude on on a humorous end
of it right I was just like they started
panning through the crowd watching him
and everybody's into it but dude there's
a picture of like a rod's face and he's
just looking at him and he's just kind
of like you could just tell us- what the
[ __ ] and like I'm watching it as just
like this guy just like in a big dress
and that kiss is makeup and I just it's
really like as and I'm not trying to
sound like a [ __ ] ignorant [ __ ] but
it's really like like just seeing him
sitting there you know no one he's got a
dick and he's dressed like that it's
it's it is humorous dude like it you
know it's it's hard to really like when
you're watching it you're like dude this
is like a guy he's like such an athlete
and then another thing that was funny he
was like you know you could pick on me
it doesn't matter he's like but show
these kids respect because they don't
know how to deal with it he's like you
know if you couldn't pick on me goes cuz
I was MVP the football team and he
standing there looking like gorgeous it
was [ __ ] hilarious that's it looks
pretty looks like they really like he
looks good I know I said that day one
when I first saw him as Caitlyn Jenner
and it's probably a hacky joke now but
day one on stage I said listen if you're
like a two or three as a guy and you're
a 10 as a woman make the move right he
looks amazing he looks great but um that
that's the thing also with comedy you
find that I'm emotional is very close to
funny like even that guy who made the
speech you said the sense
bangle guy whose daughter is living with
cancer and the cancers in remission and
all this kind of stuff he made a joke
that got a big laugh and those are my
favorite kind of laughs oh yeah when he
talked about the wife's wedding yeah
he's like don't go too crazy yeah he's
like he's like you know I love you and I
wasn't able to hug and kiss you and hold
your hand and you knew what I was going
through but I want you to know I'm gonna
give you the greatest dream wedding he
goes but don't go out and start going
crazy with the money and that got a big
laugh that was great though you know
what that's comedy like that's you know
it's like when robert schimmel told the
story about his son who was dying of
cancer and only wanted to do is drive a
car and he finally got him to get in the
car the dot you know that story right no
I don't know robert schimmel rest his
soul somebody said they saw him at
carolines I guess not too long before he
passed maybe a year a couple or a couple
years and he tells a story about how in
the 80s or I think it was the 80s or not
early 90s maybe eight he's got a
ten-year-old son who was very very sick
with cancer dying dying in a hospital
and he's telling a story about how all
the kids dream ever to do was to drive a
car so they all Kid want to do is drive
a car so he says to the doctor doctor I
want to take him out of here and I
wanted to drive the car I wanted to
drive in a car and everything and the
doctors like listen man he's in really
bad shape he's dying he goes duck the
kids dying because I want us I want to
give him this say [ __ ] let the kid
get out and Schimmel takes him and they
kind of go to like a desert e dirt area
like where there's nothing around this
is his kid or just a kid no his kid this
kid oh this is this is from the story
that I was told that he had a kid
younger and ski so he takes the kid in
the car to the desert or you know do you
know everything and he just lets this
kid he sets it up where the kid can
reach and everything and he's sitting
there and he's like in the kids driving
and he was like in the look on his kids
face and the feeling he goes it was one
of the most amazing feelings he was but
then like he starts like you know
hitting the up there in the dirt near
there in the thing and he starts hitting
things and he starts getting wild and
then Schimmel just goes and the only
thing I can think about is why didn't I
rent a [ __ ] car
uh you know and it's like but it's it's
what you said it's like those those
heartfelt stories like when it like
you're you're almost as an audience
member going how can this get funny like
where is the funny this is so serious
and then he hit it and it's like that's
the des perfect dude and you know um i
don't i'm not gonna do the whole joke
but Doug Stanhope i would i would
encourage everybody i just saw it he's
got it on netflix doug stanhope got a
bit about his mom wanting to commit
suicide because she was dying and like
do an assisted suicide and goes all
right we'll just come to my house and
we'll set you up comfortable and just
let me know when you're gonna do it and
he just talked about how they were
joking throughout the process and all
this dude and it's one of the most if
you really think about what he's saying
it's so sad but then the way he does it
it's so brilliant and like that's that's
what I love you know yeah so do i and
then and that was my other question
about the ESPYs I don't know how long
have the sb's been going well how long
20 years I think the first ESPYs was in
like I remember nor McDonald got in
trouble because his was so brutal how
like how mean he wasn't stuff and they
wanted a comedian at the time I want to
say that was around like 97 so I think
yeah I think it's probably mid-90s to
now so yeah you're looking at like you
know probably 20 yeah pretty maybe like
close to 20 years right now have they
always cuz i'm watching last night I
don't know if I'm the only one that was
thinking this watching the ESPYs last
night I'm sure I'm not and I'm sure this
is going to be talked about probably on
the news today it was like every story
was like some sort of sad story got the
woman who lost an arm followed by the
kid with cancer followed by John you
know Bruce Jenner it was just like one
sad story at the other it's like and I
don't remember the ESPYs being that and
all of a sudden it is and you wonder if
that's you know I don't want to say this
in a negative way but it is it to get to
grab viewers what is the reason that
it's this super heartfelt thing why
can't it just be um athletes when an
awards what I have I have I have a
theory on that and I
think you're right but I have a theory
on why they do that number one I think
they do it for two reasons I think that
it's only you can't just keep giving
awards out to athletes I think that they
do want to make it they do want to give
you some more deeper because you know
everybody has the idea that sports and
jocks are just you know yes [ __ ] guy
runs around like dumb jocks and stupid
sports and what about the people that
don't want sports I also think though
you get a way bigger audience because
people have gone through tough things
like that I also think you get more of
female viewership I think that like
people want to understand that these
athletes are more human than we think I
think that that's what they go for
because the non the casual sports viewer
I think the casual sports viewer just
looks at it like oh it's a game who won
oh who won that game I watched for a
little bit I think that they're trying
to pull those people in to say hey this
guy may run a 43 40 and be the most
incredible guy but you know what his
daughter sick or like like you've gone
through somebody that's sick I think
they just want to get everybody and let
everybody bring more people into sports
that's why I think they do it right I
agree with you i agree with you and
sports one of the reasons i love
watching sports is that it's like why i
like certain comet as it emotion sports
has it built in like when when something
great happens and you and you catch it
live it's different than well it's way
different than if you watch it on
youtube or something like if you happen
to be at a no-hitter which I've been to
I mean it's like you're almost crying as
you're cheering it's just a [ __ ] it's
magical when you see that something
amazing happened you know maybe this
kid's gonna win the the british open
this week like that i'm gonna watch it
it's gonna be amazing if this kid at the
age he's at is gonna win the three yes
you want to know what's funny about it
no hitter a perfect game listen to this
when david wells pitched a perfect game
for the Yankees my buddy started dating
a girl and he took her to the game she
didn't know what's going on so she's
looking around going why is everybody
into this is so boring nothing's
happening and is do you understand what
the [ __ ] is happening right now
like he couldn't have been at that game
with a worse person like because all
you're thinking about is what he was at
a perfect game with a perfect [ __ ] yeah
like how great would it be if you're at
that with a friend a brother like
somebody that like you're so close with
that could appreciate it instead you're
with some [ __ ] chick who has no idea
like what's going on in to her it's
boring because the balls not going
anywhere oh my god i was at dwight
gooden snow hit her with my brother who
was a Yankee Stadium for the first time
oh that's awesome I remember that game
that was in 96 it was we couldn't
believe it was just encourage baseball
fans to so he's at yankee stadium for
the first time we moved down and we're
sitting real close to like home plate
and to witness it was insane you know I
remember they carried him off the field
carried him off and he did that uh he
like flex to the whole crowd that was
that's awesome dude I was a junior in
high school and I remember going to
school the next day and everybody was
talking about that how awesome that was
especially with all the stuff he went
through you were at that game that's
awesome yeah great one and it was
actually an accidental being there so it
had like a backstory to it which was I
went to opening day that year I don't
think I'd ever been to an opening day at
Yankee Stadium day and it was one of
those weird uh April's where it's snowed
but they didn't cancel the game they
like played through flurries and it blew
it was freezing out and snow flurry and
I guess for some reason they felt bad
for the people that stayed and watch the
whole game also they gave you the
tickets they go you they um they gave us
an option they gave three games to pick
from and I just said for Seattle's good
that was when Seattle was good and I go
let's go but I picked the seattle game
and then I got lucky I got tickets to
the no-hitter oh it's awesome yeah what
the hell I was just gonna say something
about the SB his son of a [ __ ] I stink
I gotta get on the a.d.d meds which are
coming soon by the way I took a I took a
neuro us what does a call to i took some
sort of 5-hour neuropsychological test
about three weeks ago and i got the
results last week
and now I'm able to go back to the
neurologist with the results and get a
DD meds if I choose it was funny the guy
thought or the woman who gaming the test
thought I might have had an alcohol
problem because it was dude there was a
360 questions section in this test 360
questions she goes it won't take it out
long i'm like how that's 306 how's that
not going to take long and when we came
back for the results she goes I think
you you sped through the questions cuz
it's coming out here that you might have
an ankle alcohol problem and I go no
you're probably right and she goes with
you idiot what do you mean and my wife
was with me too and I go whoa she goes
it seemed like you thought that you
self-medicate I started laughing and I'd
been doing this on stage to him like who
doesn't drink to feel better that's self
medicating right I don't who just drinks
to drink like I've been doing it worked
really well last night it'll probably
never work again I go my life sucks and
I like I did like a sip and I go feel
great all right better now I go ah my
kid [ __ ] his pants who cares like I was
doing all these different like things
like bad and then better after the [ __ ]
yeah no this does that mean you have an
alcohol would you say that you drink to
self-medicate who does not I mean I
think that there are certain people that
don't there are certain people that
literally will sip a beer at a social
occasion just because it's kind of going
on and you know they do it and then I
think there's people that really like to
get loose but I gotta be honest with you
man I think they said eighty percent of
people have a drink like eighty percent
of people like to feel buzzed and if you
don't like to feel buzzed you're full of
[ __ ] you know what I mean maybe there is
a difference between liking to feel
buzzed and I'm in an awful mood right
now I'm gonna have a drink right see
that's different like I've never done
that i have i've never been like and I
don't understand that like like even
when that guy in the SP said when his
daughter had cancer and he just went
crying and all he wanted to do is go get
the biggest bottle of vodka and drink it
but he couldn't I've never had that
thought I've never for me I want to
drink to have a good time so like I'm
like oh man I meet my buddies i haven't
seen him in a while we're gonna argue
sports it's gonna be
grave smoke a cigar let's drink I'm
never like man [ __ ] this you know I
can't stand this [ __ ] marriage problems
money problems I'm just gonna drink it
away I've never done really we've never
like a really shitty set at a club and
then drink afterwards no I'd rather not
drink I'd rather actually I sit in that
and I try to deal with it that way I
like to drink one after i have a great
set ok so you're a fun like Lyle it's
like I went on wrong i want to make the
fun last oh I'm doing a new bit right
now it's kind of like a new opener that
I'm doing where I go I'm the type of guy
i go i'm not an alcoholic I go I just
never want the party to end I go on the
type of guy that I'm always like I'll go
to three beers tops and by the end of
the night I'm like yeah let's get heroin
[ __ ] it like I'll go to Vegas my god you
will come you are that guy I am that guy
like you know me dude like I was
literally like if I was good enough you
could probably talk me into going to
Vegas like that night like drive in
there like you'd be a you go through it
let's just buy to Vegas for two nights
will call the wise when we get there and
say something crazy app and i would
actually contemplate it yeah i told you
i think when i first met you that you're
my comedian version of the guy gene that
I explained earlier that i grew up with
he was that guy let's go or let's go um
let's go to Geno's steaks was a popular
one like we grew up right outside of
Philly so like I love Gina we come out
of the club are at work clubs only were
younger you know at two or three in the
morning and he would just look at you
and go Gino steaks and you yeah and we
just go over the bridge like it was
which is another thing that I want to
bring up and I know this is a bad
subject to bring you bring up with Paul
verzi because you're a little
hypochondriac with your health yeah um
this just happened this past week and I
want he doesn't listen to my podcast but
maybe I can tell him to listen to the
podcast one of my closest friends that I
grew up with and I it makes me realize
that I'm at that age now 48 he's 48 she
was a healthy guy like me skinny you
know pretty in shape guy sends me a text
early in the week he goes I don't know
if my wife texted you or you know gene
or Mike these two other guys that we
we were all really close growing up
texted you he goes but I just went to
the hospital they told me I had a mini
heart attack and you're like holy [ __ ]
really yeah I had a mini heart attack
and then we're thinking nothing of it
and they have to give him some they
wanted two days like that they kept him
in the hospital and they said they want
to get a cardiogram maybe I'm probably I
could look it up in my text but i don't
i'm too lazy to do it i don't know what
it's called when they test all your
arteries to see what yeah it's like it's
called is like an echo gram or
cardiogram something like that an echo
group yeah that's one two just like is
it really yeah so uh he goes I got to
get one of those on Monday and then we
get a text from his wife saying that he
got it done and he has to have triple
bypass surgery done 48 years old in in a
day he has to go in and get triple
bypass and I felt so bad because Jean
and Mike my two friends they grew up
with said we're going are you in we're
gonna go we're driving the DC they had
to put him in a hospital and data switch
hospitals that he was in put him in DC
he was probably in the Baltimore area
we're going down are you in and I go
yeah I'm in and then I started thinking
about it and I'm like you know it's a
five-hour drive I have two outs I had
shows and I got two kids I gotta watch
and then I ran it by my wife she's like
you know I kind of need your help I
don't know you know that's a lot those
guys that are going your two friends
that are going live two and a half hours
closer than you do so I'm like yeah
you're right and I and I I was the first
time a mile well maybe the second time I
did have one of my comedian friends pass
away a few years ago and I'm a year ago
and I did a podcast all about him but
still he was a comedian friend and not
like this as a guy grew up with and it
was the first time in my life that I
felt it was like a brother and it was
the first time when this went on with my
friend that I thought like and I'm
probably all over the place as I'm
explaining the story but I saw a movie
this week um and I wrote it down see if
I wrote it down in here what the hell
the name of them will
really good movie to knowing me I know I
wrote it down somewhere [ __ ] I'll see
you in my dreams actually what is the
movie and it's about this older woman
whatever and Sam Elliott is in the movie
he's [ __ ] to me that guy so good he
was so good in this movie i'll see you
in my dreams he's this older woman's
loses her husband and then she's single
for 20 years and she meets she meets Sam
Mele and I'm not gonna tell the whole
movie and he's really good in it and
there's a line where she just says I
feel like there's more I just feel like
there's more and I told my wife last
night at dinner I go I have that in that
I said the line from the movie and I
said I feel that I don't know what I'd
what the more is and somehow I don't
know if you ever do this I always
connect it to where I'm living and I'm
like you know all my there's some comedy
I don't have any friends that live 5 10
minutes or my house there's no card game
that I go to when i when i grew up we
used to play cards together on a friday
night and like i said i almost started
crying when i said this to my wife
yesterday i go you know Mike having to
get a triple bypass I said it felt like
my brother was getting a triple bypass I
go I it's just different than some of my
friends that I have up here I go I meant
it when I said I love you to him like I
was like and I'm living far from these
guys so I just felt I don't know if it's
a it's a friend disconnection and
sometimes I try to explain to my wife I
think it's a career heartbreak when
you're in a comedy career and you want
to make it and like Amy Schumer who I
totally respect and I think she's super
talented and her movies coming out today
and her name is everywhere right now and
a million people we know are in this
movie as I'm forgetting a train wreck
which is gonna do insane numbers it got
like a hundred percent on rotten
tomatoes I'm sure it's an excellent
movie I can't help but go [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] like I get my heart broken
and I'm starting on Michael do am i
turning into Marc Maron where he used to
hate louis ck I'm just like I'm happy
for these people
but I get so annoyed and sometimes I
think like certain comedians that just
go [ __ ] it like Pete Corey le to me is a
hilarious comedian and he all of a
sudden made a move and just move to
Buffalo where his wife's from and had a
kid and sometimes you get to that point
you're like why am i living near New
York getting my heart broken paying an
insane amount of money when I could go
live somewhere cheaper you know it's
like it you know what I mean but then
you feel like you're giving up if you go
do that it's confusing yeah I even
asking a question am i all over the
place no no no I mean I I kind of get
what you're saying where it sounds like
you're saying that you start feeling
complete yeah well you're starting to
think about reminisce about friends and
where you're from and you know I think
your friend having a triple bypass is
definitely a wake-up call you know cuz
it really shows the mortality of people
but now in this situation it makes it
more real for you because it's a
mortality of a kid that you treat like a
brother that you grew up with and
nobody's getting any younger and you're
just thinking you know what are you
doing what am i doing yeah like ruspin
Eve always says this and it's funny when
he says that he goes dude the next 10
years in comedy are gonna be a bloodbath
that's he always says in the net because
this is when comedians are going to
start dropping they've been dropping a
lot in the last five so imagine in the
next ten from yeah you know what's funny
you say that i started noticing that
people that I was coming up with or not
even people that I was coming up with
even younger like I'm just starting to
notice that some people are dropping off
but I look at it like this I was talking
to an agent last night and we were
talking it's like I you have to you you
have to go back you have to go back to
this about why you first did it I don't
know what your intentions were when you
first did it because me and you weren't
friends because you're the generation
that's ahead of my generation your
generation of stand-up is in the
generation of the guys that are like you
know 10 like I'm there like a generation
or two behind you so me and you didn't
hang out when you first started you were
a guy that I saw you are a guy that I
saw on TV and saw your name in the city
but when I was like year one in year two
or three in um but number one when I see
something like Amy Schumer doing what
she's doing I I know
a couple things one she's got an amazing
work ethic she's very talented and
number two I'm not competing against her
that's not that's not what I'm competing
against oh yeah I don't worry about it
sometimes I get crazy where I'm like I'm
not even jealous of Amy Schumer
sometimes I question I'm like how come
I'm never the guy that anybody puts in
any other stuff like when you see 19
comedians that you're friends with in
somebody's projects and you're like I've
never been called once to be in somebody
sketch to be like you're doing this AOL
thing what you honest papas you're doing
some sketches and stuff like that and
it's good I've never been that guy that
everybody like let's get Joe to be in
our thing like it just effort comes up
I'm like what am i doing wrong to people
not like me what is my mistake no I
think that you live far away like i do
but i also think that you know you have
kids and you're not a guy you're not a
guy that stays and hangs at the club and
has like clicky stuff nor am I you know
the only reason why the honest thing
came up with me to be honest was because
you know we have the same manager and
they were like hey you know what as far
as like comedy and sketches and sports
together and then they knew that I wrote
for the SP speaking of the ESPYs you
know I wrote for an espy awards once
before so they kind of knew that and I
got in because it's kind of in my
wheelhouse but other than like yiannis
and burr and a few other people you know
yourself you know that I would actually
call up an invite to a barbecue where my
family's at like I'm not that guy either
who's like always in a you know I have
like a handful of guys that I like in
comedy you know five guys but you'll go
to the stand when you're doing a spot
and you'll stay til 230 in the morning I
mean now I don't stay til 230 anymore
but I will stay like if i do the eight
o'clock and the eight o'clock is done
i'll usually hang out eat and like be
there like almost during the whole ten
o'clock show that that's what you know
what not as you're saying that it's
making me think oh this isn't always but
a lot of these comedians that i can
think of that are clicked with the right
comedian they get in their stuff some of
it is because they were the hosts at
that club a lot and when you're the host
which is good about the host is the MC
everybody you go up you do 10 or 15 and
then you bring in all the comedian's up
so you have to be there
night like this guy Mike Royce used to
host every nite at The Comedy Cellar now
Mike Royce is like he he is a head
writer on like everything that Ray
Romano does ray romano put him and
hooked him up with [ __ ] and then you
think of William Stevenson William
Stevenson a guy who's you know big in
comedy news this week because all the
[ __ ] that happened at the comic strip
but uh he's another guy that hosts
everywhere and you always see him
popping up in louis ck's television show
and you know maybe it's an you yanas
papas you host a lot at stint at the
stand at least you were for a while you
have to be there yeah yeah yeah when
you're there you have to be there and
you develop you definitely when your
hope that's a really good point I never
thought of it like that I don't host
there all the time I host and do spots
they're mixed but i'll tell you when i
do host it gives me relationships cuz if
i didn't host i probably wouldn't be as
cool with the you know the gary
coleman's and the Judah Friedlander is
and all these guys that like now I'm
really cool with you know and you get to
sit there and you get to talk to him
during the night or you know you know me
there's a smoke shop next door so I'll
go in there I'll grab a stick or
something i'll be outside and i'll be
you know smoking on my cigar in between
comedians and everybody's outside
talking and yeah so you kind of build
that you build that rapport with guys
and then when you do come in for a spot
you feel like you could stay in your
hang out but you know it's kind of like
when you were at the cellar you know
that the stand is kind of like that's
what everybody's telling me like you
know burn and Bobby Kelly their owns
like you know the stand is is you know
it almost seems like right now there's
two clubs it's either the stand of the
seller and obviously I'm a stand guy and
you know that's my seller from the way
you know the seller was years ago with
people you're just there you're hanging
out and these are your buddies but i'm
still not like hey man all the comedians
are going to play basketball saturday
that's not me but that's net that was
never me like you know guys oh we're all
going to so-and-so's house to watch the
fight well don't get me wrong I'll do
that very occasionally but i'm not a
quickie guy and you know that well to
alter the subject slightly whereas
people that aren't comedians I think
could relate to this and I don't know if
if you guys listening have this happen
in your lives but I feel that my
connection
where you know when you're connecting
with someone when you're not connecting
I always connect with the person that's
not this going to be the big superstar
it's always the guy who's struggling
even when i'm on a project if I'm in a
television show or in some independent
film or something like that the person I
get along with the most is like the
[ __ ] sound guy like it's never the
director or the writer it's the loser
that not the loser but it's like it's
the lower man on the totem pole and I
don't know why that is you almost said
you have to be phony to make friends
with the with the higher ups it's got to
be obvious when you read on a low part
of the totem pole yeah I mean yeah I
guess so I guess that's why la is really
big on the whole fake niceness and the
kiss in the ass because everybody is
playing that game so it almost became
culture I think that like a guy like you
and me we at the end of the day we could
hang out we could have a drink or two
but we got to get home to our kids we
got [ __ ] to do we have houses I mean
like the percentage of comedians like
everyone's like why you got a house man
how you for dead or you got you know you
got a family you got a house and your
personal life's doing really good and
it's like yeah but you know what you may
get four more spots a week than me or
you may get three more spots a week than
me because you're living here you know I
have to set my schedule right it really
is a balance for what we're doing and I
think the balance of life that we have
definitely makes it a little more you
know makes it a little more I guess
difficult to be quickly like you see
people get on TV shows are their friends
because they're just hang out with them
constantly non-stop that can never be me
right I are you I hear ya I know you're
on a time constraint so I want to get to
one question here it at the end and then
I'm gonna take on some of the more
subjects that I have some of them I've
some more the summer I got another feel
I'm all right for a little bit you are
ok because I have more I have more stuff
on my list here and then I have a
question well go to the question and
then won't go to a couple things on the
list one of the questions someone asks
and I think you'll have an answer for
this also crispy asks hey Joe what goes
through your head while you're bombing
on stage
how long into your careers did it take
to figure out the best way to work your
way through eating it that's funny I was
just in a documentary and somebody just
asked a question about bombing now what
what what it's like to do that and what
are you feeling um what's going through
your head when you're bombing the only
thing that bothers me about bombing now
because you know where I think me and
you were both at the point where we know
we're funny we've been doing it long
enough and we just kind of know listen
there's going to be some nights where
you don't have a great set and it's easy
to kind of just make it go away and say
I'm at tomorrow's another day like a day
at the office the only thing that bugs
me about it is knowing that the person
who paid money to go to that show is not
getting the best me and I'll give you an
example and this is what i said in the
documentary somebody saw Mickey Mantle
crying crying at his locker you might
know the story but Mickey Mantle was
crying at his locker at a game and one
of his teammates goes up to him and is
like Mick we crime for him or he was
just so upset he was just [ __ ] down
and he said I went 0 for 4 man and he
goes dude he goes your baseball player
is a gay probably tomorrow you know you
hit a home run the day before what do
you were you worried about and he goes
yeah but there's a kid in there who
can't afford to go to a game and finally
was able to go to the game is probably
the only time he's ever gonna see me and
he saw Mickey Mantle go for for and
strikeout and like that's kind of what
goes through my head when I'm on stage
and I'm not doing what I know I can do
and I'm very competitive I want to be
the best comedian in the room I mean I
want to be the best comedian on the
lineup and I don't give a [ __ ] who's on
a lineup I don't care who walks in the
room I want to crush to a point where
people like dude that guy and when I'm
not that and I know the crowd doesn't
think on that like when the crowds are
gone okay this is you know when you you
don't want to ever feel like the weak
link of a show and when you feel like
some people are gonna leave thinking
that that's really shitty for me and you
just know they leave and you're like one
of the guys that they don't you know
that that's that's what goes through my
head and it's like I'm not like all man
i'm a bad comedian I'm not gonna cuz I'm
just like off [ __ ] you know things
aren't working out maybe the crowd sucks
but just
knowing people are leaving thinking you
were the bottom of the show that that to
me hurts the most that's just what you
just said just made me think Chris this
isn't if you're obviously a comedian
that you're asking this question what
I've learned and I probably didn't know
this for a long time and it helps now is
if if you go to the guy who went on
before you how's the crowd because if
you didn't get a chance to watch you
don't know so either you ask the
comedian how's the crowd or you watch
how the crowd is reacting if comedians
are doing bad and then you go up and do
bad you don't care you know I don't care
if everybody's doing bad and then I go
up and I didn't do well I'm like this
crowd stinks doesn't hurt as bad that's
a great point because you see all these
good comedians struggling because it's
just a tight crowd yeah you know yeah
yeah then you don't overly judge them
and then you just go up and relax and
you don't care and if it doesn't go well
there's also a difference between
bombing with your a stuff or you're
going up and trying all new [ __ ] and
it's not working that doesn't you know
when you're bombing with your a stuff
that's when comedians even Paul you and
I both love to say really it's a [ __ ]
I love your ear line always quoted
that's a perfect [ __ ] joke well you
know your nail in this answer i really
think you are Joe cuz both points you
just said i think is great i think what
you said just now you nailed it where
it's like if the crowd sucks for
everybody you don't care and you don't
care if you're going up there telling a
brand new story you never told before
because in your mind you're like okay
this is i don't even know how this is
gonna go so you almost feel like you're
with them like how is this funny but
when you start you know when you start
throwing your gas you know you know i
mean when you start throwing you start
throwing everything you got that
normally works and the crowds not into
it but then i also say when that happens
I gotta scratch thanks you know so yeah
yeah you're right i think when you get
to be an experienced veteran comedian
you kind of can judge you know taking a
[ __ ] hot one i'm also at the point
where i can tell because they're all if
it's a 21 year old crowd and I'm up
there like I'm doing I'm doing like 15
minutes just on my trip to Israel
right now and I'm noticing it works the
best at this club called the Broadway
comedy club in New York City and it was
a club I used to never really kill at
and lately I've been killing there and
it's because i'm doing this joke all
these jokes about another country and
that is a very international audience
it's all tourists from all over the
world and now that i have material
that's about another country and you
know you're nailing it again I think you
nailed three points in this question no
you nailed three parts of this question
because that you just made me think
about you know when I go to stand up New
York a lot of times stand-up New York is
amazing but a lot of times stand-up New
York is people from you know Belgium and
people from from amstell Denmark and
people from like all of these places and
you go up there and you're kind of like
like they're not getting references
they're not getting American reference
or not anything so you can't beat
yourself up for that bomb because these
people just are getting you know taken
off the street in Times Square and they
don't get it yeah if they're 22 and you
know in your head I'm doing my set about
my two kids that they're not going to
relate with and you're just like not
gonna veer you gotta expect not as many
laughs okay so that's your question
answered crispy I hope that helps what
about that clay I nailed it I nailed it
um let's see i gotta i'll let you decide
what subject because and if Paul doesn't
get to these I'll get to these after
Paul by I could do I'll do what I could
do one with you and then I gotta run
okay i'll let you pick so I saw the Amy
White House Winehouse documentary um I
watched chef with my wife and she didn't
like it um Artie Lange and I that's what
they're gonna want to really talking
about cuz Artie Lange and I kind of made
up and everybody's been wondering what
the hell's been going on with already
and I cuz i haven't been on his podcast
in like three months maybe four months I
don't know it's been a while that I my
tweet about a-rod getting the being up
for the best comeback which I thought
was ridiculous I'm not going to tell you
what my tweet was there's that one
that's it which one you like um you
minute recess oh I date men I'll go my
wife not like in chef the Winehouse
documentary RT Lange and I makeup done a
rod on the ESPYs the RT Lange thing the
RT Lange thing is something you could
talk about on your own I'll say I'll say
either the wine house or the because i
watch this Kurt Cobain thing but I was
saying you do I would say either the
wine house or the a-rod your choice well
you're you're a big Yankee fan so I
should definitely talk to you about the
a-rod thing you'll probably disagree
with me but you might not though because
I tweeted out and a lot of people
retweeted it I said how is a rod getting
uh getting a nominated for Best come
back when he was kicked out of the
league for cheating like you shouldn't
be up for some award when you make a
comeback after being kicked out of the
league like it's like it ray rice is
never going to be up for best comeback
that's a great point I can't argue that
I mean I will say I was never an a-rod
guy ever I don't think I i was almost at
a rod's 3000th hit and i can tell you i
was being you were the games before i
was one game before and they intention
not intentionally but they threw more
balls in a row yeah i have my son we're
standing up screaming we're waiting for
the 3000 hit we think we're gonna see it
my brother was going to leave the game
early but I said you can't now cuz he's
got one more at-bat and you can see a
three 3000 hit once again I told you
there's emotions in sports but I was
there then I felt it there was a lot
less emotions and should have been there
at a home this guy's home stadium and
you could feel I'm like people are just
kind of clapping because it's 3,000 but
it's not the same as if it was Derek
Jeter going for 3000 not even close yeah
no I agree with that and I like I said I
was never an Arab guy but I do love the
year that he's having I love the fact
that everybody that said he was done and
he's kind of given like a [ __ ] you and
he's he's actually buckled down and he's
really play
in good baseball for the Yankees so here
I'm ad didn't cut you off here but I
don't mind him doing it having a great
comeback but I don't mind you nominating
him for best comeback on this emotional
great story ESPYs awards that they're
trying to do like what then anyone was
that a popular subject am I the only one
to be saying this that can't be this has
to be huge I i agree i think given him a
comeback thing is weird it's like come
back from what his punishment you know
you don't get out of jail you don't get
out of jail and get a [ __ ] merit for
like not killing somebody like you know
a year after getting out of jail he
murdered people but now he's not
murdered yeah yeah he's out of jail he
didn't murder for you know 14 months a
straw man award no it's like uuu I love
that point because yeah it's like he he
he put that on himself he had to come
back because of the situation I put in
something so I agree yeah i agree with
that I mean like I said I room for the
uniform you know you gotta root for the
uniform no I mean I'm sure there's a you
know if somebody raped a guy on your
team you don't obviously like the guy
you think the guy's a piece of [ __ ] but
you're not gonna not ever root for your
team again right I gotta I gotta be
honest as an eagle fan when michael vick
was the quarterback and i'm not even an
animal guy I had trouble rooting for him
as much as I would for somebody else
without a tainted past when I agree with
that to this extent you did that but
when he threw a 60-yard bomb I clapped
know when he threw a 60-yard bomb and
you're hoping to God that receiver
catches you're gonna go nuts yeah that
guy catches i will but it's much
different when you watch your guy who
you know shows character like a Derek
Jeter I'm trying to think who a
Philadelphia Eagles character player
would be I mean I can think of like
Brian Dawkins was a guy that I loved
when he was on the Eagles I mean this
guy was a [ __ ] animal on the field
and he just I don't know I respected him
it was just different I'm trying to mike
schmidt as a Philly like they didn't
they weren't pieces of [ __ ] come on this
is bad that i'm not saying that michael
vick's a piece of [ __ ] but I mean the
crime that he did right so it's kind of
bad
yeah yeah like I'll let you go I forgive
you but come on we're not giving you
awards yeah i think that i think that
the a-rod comeback thing i do think that
that's a little weird it's like you
kicked him out and now he's getting a
combat award maybe because he was I mean
the only thing I could think of as maybe
because he's hurt I don't think there
was a lot of comeback I think the ESPYs
had to give it to somebody I don't think
there was a lot of other nominees that's
the other thing like they're probably
going down the list like should we get a
ride i mean i don't know there's only
like three other guys and nothing's good
enough so i think that they kind of had
to I don't think that there was other
great comeback stories but I'll tell you
this before I go cuz i do better run
okay but I'll tell you this um you know
I'm really big on you know me and I
don't know what's happening to me but
the older I get the more I get into
conspiracy theories and the more that I
really believe i believe that um I'm
just a guy when there's smoke there's
fire if a lot of people pick out things
that aren't right with something and
then you really look into it I actually
think they're things that aren't right
you know that being said I mean we could
sit here and we could talk about aliens
and we could talk about all these crazy
things that people talk about JFK 911
all those things aside but I will tell
you that you know the one weird thing
about that Kurt Cobain um documentary
and you know you brought up the
Winehouse thing was when I was watching
it it's like you gotta look at evidence
and I don't know I mean I know that
there was like an a suit a suicide note
and stuff but the fact that there was no
and it's got the the doc is called Kurt
and Courtney I don't know if you saw it
but it's on netflix that must be a
different one there was one on HBO that
there's he's got like two out the one
you saw was a recent one that they
played at the south by southwest
festival and that's a newer one but
there's one an older one where an
investigator was going around because
there was a lot of speculation that Kurt
Cobain was murdered and Kurt Cobain was
murdered at the hand of or the hiring of
of Courtney Love and Courtney Love's
album came out like the week that the
week that he died her album dropped also
and listen I don't want to sit here and
say you know false accusations about
somebody I'm just telling what the
documentary was about
the questions at the documentary raised
but then it was like you know she was
constantly talking about his will weeks
before he died or like a month before he
died then another musician who was
almost like this like big almost like
like uh like he would do like like porno
/ rock video stuff and he was like this
guy he was nuts and they went to go talk
to him and he said that courtney love
offered him fifty thousand dollars to
whack Kurt Cobain and in the process of
the documentary the guy died they found
his body on the train tracks and all
kinds of weird stuff but the weirdest
thing about it was uh the shotgun that
he used had zero prints on it not even
his own and like so the guy who
supposedly put a gun to his [ __ ] head
and the investigator one of the lead
investigators to this day says there's
absolutely no way the guy killed himself
but the lead investigator was like how
can you have a shotgun shooting and and
there's not even a print forget a print
of a killer his print is not on it so
that that has to indicate that
absolutely indicates tampering with that
weapon after the trigger was pulled now
could it have been somebody that found
him and got scared and wiped it may be
but it doesn't sound right and all the
talk about and then her father was
saying stuff so again I'm not gonna sit
here and speculate but watch that
documentary and watch what was going on
in his life and the things that he was
doing I mean they it was just really
really weird and it was really
interesting so you brought the wine
house thing up and so that's why I just
wanted to bring that up well I'll have
to check out that documentary I only saw
the other one and the other one was like
so voyeuristic it was uncomfortable you
know to the point where they're just
like hanging out with cameras on and
she's taking her clothes off and walking
around I don't know if you saw it but
it's now it's kind of odd it's like one
step away from them just turning the
cameras on in their bedroom and have it
sex like they're just hanging out for
like the whole movies like just this
home video almost and it's really good
here's the thing too if you I mean I
guess this happens but like if you were
to kill yourself there's a dark podcast
word would you do with a [ __ ] shotgun
I know
now take a couple of pills put on a
movie you know like you're not a movie
not a good movie but like you know let
me just take some take some things to
relax and you fall asleep like to go to
the measure of just putting a shotgun to
blood I got something weird with that
man I don't know I had to explain the
word suicide to my seven-year-old son
this week which was very odd he was he
was telling me that these kids at camp
just will like they think it's funny and
they'll just go hey yeah so is that
suicide and I'm like do you know what I
had to say something I go don't scream
suicide he's like why I go do you don't
know what it means but it's it's bad and
then I explained to him what it what
happens and some people have something
wrong with their brain and it makes them
very sad thank God my son goes I love
life he goes I love life so who would
want to do that I go with some somebody
sick whose brains not working right
thank God he go he didn't go yeah yeah
that sounds fun well listen brother and
now that's that's that's awesome we'll
leave on suicide ah enjoy your day I'll
see you too I'll see you I'll see you at
levity tonight man I'm gonna run a
couple minutes I appreciate it i'll see
you there and we'll see a movie after do
you know what maybe you wanna see ya
yeah well check will check it out we'll
see what we'll see what the time is I
mean I still gotta do my podcast maybe
I'll bring my stuff and you'll be online
okay um why I need plugs because of my
my dates at the the universe or the
night University the New Haven gig Joker
also you cannot speaking of plugs real
quick just uh for your listeners and
everything guys I'm gonna be headlining
I'm gonna be headlining left Boston next
weekend july twenty third to the 25th
day yeah they saw me there with the
all-in tour they asked me back to
headline i'm extremely excited about it
so and i just went on that run with bert
when bur did those 19 straight shows at
the wilbur i was there with him for 16
of them so of you for you people out
there that enjoyed the show and
everything you know instead of me doing
20 i'm gonna be headlining laughs Boston
a twenty-third to the 25th so come out
get tickets I heard tickets are actually
being sold so I'm excited about it check
me out at Paul verzi calm and go to my
@paul verzi tonight I will be with the
legendary joe Matarese at the levity
live in one of my favorite comedy clubs
in the country so come out and check out
the Virgin fecht podcast which will be
out later today thanks Joe all right man
later they're going there he was the
great Paul verzi with 1400 plugs that
was a lot of plugs uh now you can tell
that he was on skype you probably hear
the difference in the mics so I had
other stuff that I wanted to talk about
I don't really know how much of it we
can get into the Winehouse documentary
that he brought up go see it it's
excellent really liked it she was a
super talent really sad story I didn't
even realize and it was obvious that she
was bulimic didn't even realize it until
I saw the documentary I'm like oh my god
it's obvious so sad so talented such a
shame and what can I say great
documentary highly recommend it my wife
not liking chef that hurt my feelings of
any am I the only one out there just I
love that movie maybe nothing's
happening but I just I don't know maybe
it's the artistic pneus in me I enjoy
just watching him cook even though it's
a movie and he's probably not doing it
but it looked like he was doing a lot of
it and it was fascinating and I love
food and I love watching people do that
kind of stuff same reason I like
distress painting and all that when I
see somebody good at or when I been
doing it lately and it makes me lose
myself and what I'm doing i feel like
i'm making a piece of art if you want to
go see my distress stuff and some of the
other painting that I've done go to my
facebook page facebook.com backslash the
joe Matarese oh you can see all my stuff
up there and like i said earlier at the
beginning of the podcast you can hire me
and i'll do some stuff another thing
that I'm reaching out if any of you fans
would like to hire somebody to work with
you on stand-up comedy many of you guys
are comics or interested in comedy I'm
giving these classes via Skype hour-long
one on ones which
just me on skype if you're interested we
want any want to I you want to hire me
to do that kind of stuff go to Matarese
67 @ gmail.com that's my email my direct
email email me if you would like to take
one of those classes and if you have
feedback for me on my podcast go to
Matarese 67 @ gmail.com and send me some
stuff all right uh what else is on my
list here mmhmm yeah I was weird that my
wife didn't like that movie out of it I
don't know she was like I'm getting kind
of bored I'm like I know I love watching
nothing happen is that weird I love
movies that almost nothing's happening
the movie that I just described earlier
uh that is on my list here i'll see you
in my dreams it's it almost doesn't feel
like a movie like i like those kind of
movies where it's like minimal instead
of over the top over the top never
brings me in you know okay i think you
do know so check that out let it a i
mention already lying i'm sure you guys
and I should probably end with this
subject rd and I spoked for a long time
a few days ago he's on his way to the
Montreal Comedy Festival he's probably
up there already i know he's doing all
the nasty shows and they're recording
something for showtime he's hosting one
of the nest he shows it'll be on
showtime and already and i had a little
late and we worked it out we'll talk
about it on his podcast when he comes
back from montreal you guys that listen
to my podcast and listen to his and you
probably listen to nicked Apollo's too
you've been asking me over and over
again now it did have it had nothing to
do with money okay they might have made
it look like that it did not there was a
situation he worked it out i will be on
his podcast again to talk about it in
great detail like I said RT quitter calm
podcast for all you subscribers to his
podcast
when he gets back from Montreal I will
go on his podcast and hopefully I'll
start doing it again it will probably it
won't be four days a week but it might
be one or two days a week okay as long
as he'll have me I love doing artis
podcast love the guy and wish him well
okay I hope I explained that I can't get
into details until I'm sitting with him
and his mics are on and we can explain
it in a way that it could you know we're
both there so it doesn't sound like
we're talking behind each other's back
you didn't hear him talk about me on his
podcast he won't hear me talking about
him without him he there you know what
I'm trying to say I think you do okay
everybody i hope you enjoyed this
podcast i think it was a good one thanks
to paul verzi go to paul verzi com if
you want to see all this stuff come and
see us live tonight at levity live this
way I what am I saying this weekend no I
will be at the New Haven gig new haven
connecticut if you live in that area
i'll be a Joker's wild on the
thirty-first of july and the first of
august okay go to joe Matarese calm the
link to buy tickets is right there the
new splash page website coming soon all
the stuff you need to buy tickets listen
to podcast make donations it's all on
joe Matarese calm the twitter the
facebook everything it's all there
follow me follow me follow me okay you
guys I hope by me trying to fix me I
help you fix you a little bit I love my
wife I love my kids keep downloading the
podcast everybody have a great rest of
your week okay and some nice prayers in
your head
for my friend Mike little Mike gerlach
guy you're my brother Mike I love you
wishing great things for you speedy
recovery it looks like i'm looking at my
phone so that your wife just texted me a
picture and I love you man night yes
prayers are my friends Mike everybody
he's a good man that I love you guys
talk to you soon
you